- Hello friends, it's me again,
your favorite person, Louis.
You know, it's comin' up on my birthday,
and I'll be 58 years old.
And I've been kinda depressed lately,
because I was thinking
about way back when I was,
from the start of when I, I can remember,
I think my first memory I can remember,
I was about about 5 years old,
and I can remember that they kinda threw
a halfway kinda party with me,
and matter of fact, two nights before that
was when Selaitha, anyway Selaitha
had started molesting me.
So that guilt was, even at five years old,
that guilt was on my conscience,
and I remember, I'm gonna
talk about the way I feel,
I remember when I was around my family,
I felt so empty, so afraid.
So I felt like I was the
worst person in the world,
I felt like there was nobody could ever be
as bad as me, why was
I the one to get cursed
with this lady all up on top me,
and we with my nose all between her legs,
and I'll never forget that
fuckin' smell, god damn.
'Course I like it now, but back then.
(Louis laughs)
Anyway, so anyway, we threw
this birthday party for me,
we had this little dog, the
little dog's name was Mimi,
and the poor little dog, I mean,
the little thing was a little
cocker spaniel or whatever.
I remember for some reason,
well let me back up.
That was around about the time my mother
and father used to get into
a lot of physical fights,
and my father would beat my mother,
he would literally beat my mother.
And that hurt me so bad,
and I always felt like,
for some reason, I felt
like that was my fault,
because my dad was always,
he was gettin' on my case,
worse than the rest of the kids,
I'd get the most whoopin's,
I'd get the most cursin' outs,
the most talkin' to, the
most, "You ain't shit."
And I never heard that
to the other children,
so that made me feel,
I'm telling my feelings,
so my feelings, that's
what I'm talkin' about,
my birthday and my feelings, my feelings
were really fucked up,
but then I had nobody
to talk to, you know?
And some of these feelings
that I locked down way back,
'cause I was five years
old, even though now I'm 58,
and they never go away,
they never go away,
they're still down, packed,
packed, packed down.
I remember once I went to a drug rehab
and one guy kinda figured it out.
He said, "Louis," he said,
"Who are you close to in here?"
There was maybe about
50 people in the room,
and I couldn't point out one person.
He says, "Somethin' you did as a child,
"somethin' has you bound,
has you locked down,
"there's somethin'
happened to you deep, deep
"and got your spirit sunk down,
"and you need to talk about that
'and pull that shit up," you know?
So now that I'm like 58 years old,
this shit is startin' to come up,
and thank God for this YouTube channel,
even though it's embarrassing, it helps me
to talk about this shit.
Fuck y'all, I'm getting off of it,
it's makin' me feel better,
you know what I'm sayin'?
So hey, you know.
(Louis laughs)
I thank God for this little camera
I'm doin' this in front of.
So you know, I, oh, still
with the birthday party,
and I remember it was my birthday party
and all the bigger kids, the bully Jenard
down the street, he was a bully,
Terry and Jenard, they
were bullies of mine,
they would beat me up and everything.
And I remember I got a tricycle,
I got a little red
tricycle, with these little
golden wheels, and I would
get out on the sidewalk,
and I'd go down, and then the next day
after my birthday, there was this guy
about three doors down, he
had just paved his driveway
with this most beautiful white,
and I know what cement
and shit like that is now,
what masonry is now, back then I know,
it seemingly just looked like the sidewalk
was so ugly, we lived in a poor town,
so the sidewalks had big bumps,
so you ride your tricycle,
you turn your tricycle,
you ride your bicycle, you
break all your damn spokes.
The side roads is all fucked up,
but this particular driveway
was real nice and smooth,
so I thought, I said, "I wanna ride
"my new tricycle on the new little,"
and I remember the old man, he's standin'
in front of the house,
I guess he's standin'
in front of the house
lookin' at his driveway like,
"Wow, I did a good job," and here I go,
(Louis laughs)
I drove the bike through, you know how,
usually when they make these little,
they tie these little lines up,
I drove the tricycle right
through the fuckin' lines
and drive in a big circle
in that man's driveway.
And I was five years
old, I never will forget
the expression on that man's face,
that man looked at me,
and he was a white guy,
he said, "You little
nigger," he grabbed me
by the back of my shirt like that,
he grabbed me and that fuckin' tricycle.
He took me to the house,
he banged on that door,
he said "Miss so-and-so,
you said you'd get
"this goddamn nigger,
he just put that bicycle
"on my damn on my damn concrete,
"and if you and your husband don't pay,
"I'm comin' and I'm fuckin' everybody."
I remember he was specifically
sayin' that to my mother,
my mother's like. (gasps)
She took me in the house,
dude she whooped my ass,
and the thing was, I felt so,
I'm talkin' about my feelings,
I mean what I did was wrong,
but I didn't know, I just, I didn't know.
The guy was standin'
there, he coulda told me,
I was always kinda slow, I
was never snappy, snappy,
I was slow, I'm still kinda like that.
So the guy, I remember
the guy standin' there,
he's lookin' at me with his arms folded,
and I mean dude I was five years old,
I swear I remember it
like it was yesterday.
He's a big, big tall white guy,
big tall like Donald Trump,
big ugly motherfucker.
And he's standin' there,
and he coulda said,
"Hey man, don't go," he
just watched me do it.
(Louis laughs)
He just didn't want, but I remember,
my mother whooped my ass,
my brother whooped my ass,
my sister punked me, and my
father, he put the leather belt,
he put, my father tore my ass up.
So that was from my birthday time,
so that set me off on a collision course
for the rest of my life, because I thought
I was the worst person in the world.
The babysitter molested me,
I fucked up the man's yard,
I had, oh I was, all
the kids, I was afraid
of the kids, I was afraid
of all the big guys,
I was afraid of 'em, so
they're diggin' their hands
in my cake, and I'm too
scared of 'em to say,
"Hey man, get your hands out my cake,"
and now I'd beat the fuck, but now I was,
I'm sittin' like some
kinda fuckin' pussy dude,
and I'm just sittin' like this,
and they're tearin' up my cake.
My mom's over there, they're drinkin'
and doin' their thing in their rooms,
but we said watch your cake Donald,
watch your cake Louis, watch your cake,
and sittin' there shakin',
scared, "You guys, you have,"
I didn't even get a piece of
the fuckin' cake, you know?
(Louis laughs)
That was my first memories
of one of my first birthdays.
Now, the second one I can remember was,
I was about, oh I had
to be 15, 16 years old.
And I remember we went to
one of my cousins' house,
and they stayed in a
kinda ritzy little area,
but they had little white
girls up and down the street,
runnin' down there, and I remember,
(Louis laughs)
well you guys know me,
I remember there was
this little white girl
who lived down the street,
she used to wear these nice little skirts
with these little, and
I guess I was about 16,
she may have been about 14 or 15,
and she would always come down there and,
"Hey Louis," and come down
on her little pink bicycle
with the little basket on the front,
and she'd come there, "Hey Louis,"
she'd come down and she'd wave at me,
and my little dick started
gettin' hard for her.
"Hey, check this out, why
don't you come up here
"in the garage?"
So one day, (laughs), I
took her up in the garage,
a lot of times I would mess with them,
but that one didn't
work, 'cause I remember
when I took her up in there,
I'm gettin' off this shit,
I remember when I took her up in there,
she said, "Why are you closin' the door?"
I was a little, I was gon'
do somethin' with her,
so you know, I kinda pushed
her up against the wall,
and I tried to go up in her, and she,
"Oh, no, no," she pushed me off
and she ran home and told her father.
Oh my god.
She ran home and told her
father, they said nothin' to me,
they said somethin' to my mother.
And my mother never told my father,
because my father would
have fuckin' killed me,
but my mother, she put me in the room,
she made me take all my clothes off,
she made me sit in the room
with no clothes on for 24 hours,
I couldn't wear clothes for 24 hours.
She said, "I'm gonna embarrass you
"like you embarrassed me in
front of that little girl.
"Now you're gonna sit in front of all,
"and eat dinner and everything,
"with no fuckin' clothes on", I sure did.
That' happened.
And here's a story.
I went to Arkansas, we
got family in Arkansas,
I went to Arkansas, I guess I was about,
this is one of the stories
I've never told anybody,
'cause I don't know what happened.
I was about nine, 10 years old,
it was around about my birthday,
and they had these chicken coops
where they fought chickens,
and they had this little barn in the back,
and I was always a little sneaky,
little kinky motherfucker, you know?
I always liked the little white girls,
I always liked the white girls,
and I remember there was
a couple of white girls,
I don't know, but where I was at,
you don't speak to no white girl,
you don't talk to no white girl,
you don't wave at no white girl,
and you damn sure don't whistle
or hits you no white girl,
'cause they'll hang your ass
out there where I was at.
I'm a little kid, I'm about 10,
I don't know nothin' about it.
Now I, to this day, I don't know,
out of bein' traumatized,
I don't honestly know
what I did.
They took me out, it
was in the summertime,
it was like in July
sometime in the summer,
they took me out, all I had
on was a pair of shorts,
and a pair of thongs, and they tied me
to a motherfuckin' tree,
and left me out there
for two fuckin' days with
nothin' to eat and water,
and I remember that lady sayin',
"You will never ever
do what you did again,"
but to this day, I don't
know what the fuck I did.
I don't know if I was traumatized,
but they tied me to a
tree for two fuckin' days.
It might've been longer than two days,
but I remember the mosquitoes,
and the bugs, and the
potato bugs, and the wasps,
whatever those little things,
and I remember a couple of
bees stung me on the neck.
But I remember prayin',
I said, "God, don't,"
and I remember thinkin'
bears were gonna get me,
and sometimes, when I
think back about this,
'cause I never talked about it,
'cause I wonder if it really happened,
to me it's so bizarre, I
coulda been dreamin' it,
that I coulda dreamed it
and just thought one of
the dreams I had, but
no, it wasn't a dream,
it's somethin' I did with
those white girls in that barn,
but I don't know what, I did somethin'
with those white girls and
they wanted to kill me,
they wanted to kill me.
That was a birthday I remember.
And oh, I remember the
first birthday I had,
I'm not gon' find that, I
remember the first birthday
I had after I had my child, oh god.
Oh god.
The way I felt.
I thought about even though,
even though my parents abused
me physically and mentally,
but they financially took
care of me, so I was,
so here my child was, I had given her up,
I turned, I think I turned, I don't know
what age I turned, I might've turned 41
or somethin' like that, and I
hadn't done anything for her,
and if I look back on it today,
what I'm depressed
about because I actually
can honestly say that my poor child
had nothin' to do with me
bringing her into the world,
because she's my sperm,
and I have a resentment
against her, because I wouldn't, my excuse
for not doin' anything for her is because,
"Well you don't want me no way,
"because they gave you to my sister."
When we went to court,
if I get honest about it,
so I resent my sister
too, but if I get honest
about the way I feel about my part,
I fucked up, because I signed her over
because the judge looked
at me, and for, oh god,
he looked at me and he was
gon' give me another chance.
(Louis sobs)
You know, he looked at her mom and said,
"Her mom was a washout, push
her to the side, fuck her."
He said, "You, you sit over there,"
because I'm sittin'
there 'cause I got tears
comin' to my eyes, I'm sittin' there,
and she's sittin' there
with her gay girlfriend,
my daughter's mother has a gay girlfriend,
and they're sittin' over there
with their homosexual asses,
looking at each other's eyes.
They just start thinkin' about,
"How do we eat each
other's pussy tonight,"
and I was in there
wondering what's going on
with my daughter.
So my poor sister's sittin' in the back
of the fuckin' courthouse,
and she's beggin' me, "Oh
please, let me have her,
"let me take care of her, let
me have her, let me have her,"
So I says, "Okay, I give up might rights,
"I just give up my fuckin' rights."
Worst thing, the best
thing I could do for her,
but for me, it put a sword, like Sinbad,
all the way through my heart,
through the front and out the back.
It was one in there, and Paul, "The Bible"
talked about a thorn in his side,
I got one goin' through my heart.
And there seems like the
only way to release the pain
is to take a drink, so lately
I haven't been drinking
and so, that's why I'm depressed,
because I haven't been drinking.
Well, hey I ain't got
no money to be drinkin',
I don't have no income comin' in anymore,
so I have to hustle and do
all these different things
to get money.
When I was smokin',
when I was high on crack
all the time, well hell, I could,
you know what I did one time,
what I did one time on my birthday?
I broke into a house, now
let me tell you somethin'.
You look at, I ain't no, I
don't be breakin' in no house,
and I looked at, and
I walked by the house,
and the fuckin', and the
fuckin' door was cracked open.
Well hell, I looked in
the crack and I said,
"Well shit," 'cause I was
high, I was high on that shit,
I needed a hit, "Well let me see."
I snuck in the house, and
I'm goin' in the house,
I walk into the house,
I'm pickin' up little
and I think, there's a lady and a man,
they're both in the bed,
they're both stark naked,
I guess they'd been screwin'.
They're in the bed, they're layin' there,
and I see the man's jeans, I
remember they were Levi's 501s,
they were layin' on the floor,
and I could see the man's wallet kinda
stickin' out the back.
So I looked around, and I'm
high, and my eyes are all big,
and I picked the pair of pants,
and I actually pulled
the wallet out the pants,
and I opened it up, and I'm countin'
the fuckin' money in there.
I mean, just the average
person with any kinda brain
woulda took the fuckin' wallet, and bam,
took the fuck off.
I'm standin' there
countin' the fuckin' money,
I'm just countin', and I
set the wallet back down,
I put them in my pocket, $300.
I put $300 in my pocket,
and I'm in these people's
jewelry boxes and shit, I'm goin',
he had a really nice Longines watch,
I got the Longines watch,
I got some fake jewelry
and beads, whatever the girl has,
and I grabbed those, and I remember,
I actually went in the kitchen
and they had a half of a subway sandwich.
I actually took that subway sandwich,
I love milk, chocolate milk,
and I took some Nestle Quick
chocolate milk, and I
poured it in a glass,
I sat down and ate the sandwich,
and drank the goddamn, they're in the bed,
and I don't know how I did that.
That one time.
So another time, I thought I could do it.
(Louis laughs)
- [Interviewer] You didn't get caught?
- Oh I'm gettin' there.
That particular time I didn't get caught.
So, I guess it was about maybe three
or four months later, I
wanted to try that shit again.
So, I'm walkin' around this neighborhood,
and I knew where the mounts end,
I'm just pullin' doors,
I'm just walkin' up,
I'm dressin', I'm just checkin' doors.
Well, one of them damn doors opened.
When I went, I'll never forget,
I opened the door, and it scared me,
and when I opened the
door, there was a lady
sitting in a wheelchair, and she looked
just like the Mona Lisa,
real spooky lookin',
and she's sittin' in
that chair with a half a,
I remember when I saw that lady,
and I got my hand, I'm opening,
I hear,
and I'm lookin' at this
lady rockin' in the chair,
she didn't scream, she didn't holler,
and I remember bein' so terrified,
I couldn't fuckin' move.
I was like, "Oh shit, the big guy's gon'
"come out with the bat, the little boys
"are gon' come 'round there with Sparky,
"and Jean gon' come around
the back, the dogs,"
I couldn't move.
I know I stood there two or three minutes,
I know I did.
Not a word was said, we
were just standin' there.
We were just fuckin' standin'.
I remember walkin' down the street,
and to this day, I don't
know if it was God,
I remember walking down the street,
and I remember the cops drove by,
and they said, "Hey, have you seen a guy,"
they gave me a description,
and now listen to this guys,
they were lookin' for a white guy.
(Louis laughs)
They obviously with Black people,
they usually saw the white people and say,
"Have you seen the Black?"
And no they said, "Hey,
have you seen a white guy
"about so tall with glasses?"
"Oh no, no," I know
they're lookin' for me.
"Oh no, you know what, it
was a guy on a red bicycle,
"I think he went on a red bicycle."
Oh yeah, so I got away with that one.
I never did that fuckin' shit again.
So anyway, oh damn.
I got up off that shit.
So as time went on, I
would have my birthday
around my daughter's, my birthday comes,
and I started thinking about my daughter.
So, the first, I would say
nine, 10 years of her life,
I'm not lyin', I'm not exaggeratin',
the fire department, or the LAPD,
or the Long Beach PD, whatever,
would wake me up, and I would
have a bottle of liquor,
and I would have drank 'til I literally,
and the fire department or the paramedics
had to put that stuff
that they put in your nose
to get you to wake up.
And one time, one time they couldn't.
Man, god damn I remember this,
one time it at The Wiener Schnitzel,
and I know it was real
cold, like it is today,
and I remember The Wiener
Schnitzel had a big,
giant roof on it, where
you get up on there
when it's cold, and it
had the slight walls,
where the wind couldn't get to you,
and I could get up under
there with my old jacket
and wrap up and go to sleep.
I got up there and I had
a fifth of Jack Daniel's,
and I drank the fifth,
and I remember when I was
up under that, I remember
I was under there,
and I remember the paramedics
tryin' to wake me up,
and it was like my body was there,
but my spirit was somewhere else,
because I remember the paramedics said,
"Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up,"
and they was puttin'
that stuff in my face,
and some white guy was doin'
the mouth to mouth resuscitation,
and I could hear him,
and I was wanting to say,
"Hey, I acknowledge you,
I'm alive, I'm awake,"
but I think I might've
been about two shades
from bein' dead, I think
I was about two shades
from bein' dead, and
finally, I don't know,
one of the guys, one of the officers,
matter of fact, I could
remember somebody sayin',
"I think we're losin' him."
And I remember pullin'
somethin' outta my soul,
'cause I ain't ready to go.
I remember somebody (claps),
somebody goin' like that,
and I don't know who
did it, it was somebody
in another spirit, or if
it was one of the cops,
but somebody was just
(claps), and all of a sudden,
I woke up.
And I remember the officer
said, "What's goin' on?"
And I broke down and cried, I said,
"My daughter's birthday,"
And the guy, he brought
me some hotdogs, the cop!
He took me home, well he took
me to my grandmother's house,
he was a real nice guy, he really is.
But I mean, I tell him, and he said,
"You don't have to drink," he said,
"Well what are you gonna do different?"
And I keep sayin' I'm gonna
do somethin' different,
and every birthday I do the same thing,
I get loaded again.
Well, after that birthday, I felt like,
I went to rehab, but after that birthday
I felt like, if this guy
can care enough about me,
then I said, "Why can't
I care about myself?"
That once I stopped tryin' to kill myself,
as far as like that on my birthday,
tryin' to drown it out, and
start dealin' with the shit.
Now I still get drunk, but I
get drunk and talk about it.
(Louis laughs)
You know what I'm sayin'?
Even if I'm talkin' at the bus stop
and ain't nobody at the bus stop,
(Louis laughs)
I talk about it.
So, those are the kinda birthdays I had.
Now, this is, not gonna take one,
I'm tryin' to see it, but now,
Christmas went by and New Year's went by.
I kinda did okay, but you
know what I did on Christmas?
I sat up in the house, don't freak on me,
I sat up in the house, no
TV, no radio, no nothin'.
Blinds closed, lights off.
I sat there like a fuckin' zombie,
feelin' sorry for myself, "Oh poor me,
"why do I have to be an alcoholic?
"Why do I have to be a crack head?
"Why do I have to have
these molestation issues?
"Why did I mess with a little girl myself?
"Why was life so fucked
up and so bad as a kid?"
And I really needed to come here and talk,
but I really needed somebody to talk,
I needed to get off of that shit,
but that happened to me on Christmas,
and then when they came over to New Year's
and everybody was outside my apartment,
they were cookin' and
celebratin' and shit.
And I had a fifth of
Bacardi and about $20 rock,
and I'm sittin' there, and
I'm thinkin', you know,
and I remember sayin',
"I'm gonna do this shit
"and I'm gonna stop
fuckin' with this shit,"
and I drank that.
I remember the JD made me so sick,
and then the cocaine I bought was fake.
I said, "Well maybe
God's giving me a sign,"
so I threw all that shit
in the trash, swore it off,
"I ain't never, ever, ever, ever doin'
"that shit again," well goddamn it,
two days later, I had another fifth,
and another goddamn rock.
So then I said to myself, "Well, here
"my stupid ass go again," I said,
"Oh, you know what?"
But you see, I keep
guivin' up, I don't know
why I keep givin' up, I keep givin' up,
and long story short, I met this lady.
You know, this lady felt
like she was 27 years old,
said she was 27 years old,
she was as tall as a fart
and had an ass wide as
a Lincoln Continental,
I mean she was fine homie, she was fine.
And she didn't have anywhere to stay,
she come outta down south, I didn't know
she at my place, the fuckin' bitch.
I was very nice to her,
and she said, "Well, I don't really want
"a boyfriend, you're too old for me,"
I said, "Fine, well
God," I told God, I said,
"Well maybe I can help
somebody to get me outta me."
And it was working.
I didn't drive, she
didn't drink, so I didn't,
I knew she didn't drink.
But lookin' at her fat
ass layin' on the floor,
I was gonna get in that ass she had,
and I wanted to, I told her, I said,
"Look," I went on to her, I said,
"I'm real nice to you, you know,
"but it's gettin' to me.
"I know you're young, you're
like a daughter to me,"
I said, "but you layin' on my damn floor,"
I kept saying, "get in
the bed, get in the bed,"
thank God she, if she'd got in the bed
I probably would've, if
she woulda got in the bed
I know I woulda took the,
I know she was adamant,
she would not get in that fuckin' bed,
and it's even cold,
she's out on the floor.
You know, so she left
her shit in my house,
so I'm down at the Mission,
gettin' somethin' to eat,
and I was, I just
wanted, I'm such a pussy,
I couldn't just tell her, "Get
your stuff outta my house,"
'cause she started usin' me.
She started seein' how nice I was,
and the fuckin' bitch started usin' me.
So, she had all this shit in my corner,
and I saw some bugs comin' out,
and I don't want, she's
bringin' bugs in my house,
I said, "Well, next time I see her,
"I'm gonna let her know
she's gotta get her shit,
"she gotta get the fuck out."
So, she came over the next time,
I was too, I pussied out again,
"Okay, well go ahead, let me
get you somethin' to eat,"
I even gave her the food, and
now I'm a big fuckin' pussy.
And I'm tryna think, "How
am I gon' get the girl
"out my house?"
Well finally I told her, "The manager says
"you can't stay here
no more," so she left,
but she left her stuff there.
And she'd come every couplea days,
and one day she came over there
and I had a girl in the
room, we were smokin' crack,
and she's downstairs, and
I made her wait outside.
She couldn't understand why
"Well, I'm just comin' to get my shit."
So I said, "Well, wait
a minute, this bitch
"is blockin' my pussy, and she
ain't even give me no pussy."
I let her come up, she saw the girl there,
and they exchanged words,
and she took out her stuff,
but even when I was tryin' to figure out
how to get her outta there,
and then the fuckin' bitch,
I saw her, I went down
to get somethin' to eat
at the Mission, and she
passed me, and she said,
"Oh, me and are gonna have," you know how
they get fellas, "Oh nigger,
me and you gon' have issues,"
that's all, and I heard, and
it was one of those days,
those days when Mister Louis
don't wanna be fucked with,
I don't want nobody sayin' nothin' to me,
it ain't personal,
don't say nothin' to me,
don't look at me and especially,
don't come at me sideways.
And I told her, I said, "I'm a nice guy,
"but I will flip on your
ass, I will flip on your ass,
"and I'll go straight the
opposite way," I said,
"Don't push me, don't come at me sideways,
"and we be cool.
"You ain't my girlfriend,
we ain't fuckin', so don't."
So when she saw me,
that day I didn't wanna
see her at all, I didn't wanna
see her fuckin' ass at all,
I just, and that was personal,
'cause her shit was in my
house, that was personal.
So when she saw me, she
said, "Oh, me and you
"gon' have issues 'bout my stuff
"and I can't get my stuff," you
know how those bad girls do.
And I looked at her, and
I just passed her on by,
'cause I know me, I said,
"Let me pass the bitch on by,
"'cause I'm gon' go off
on the motherfucker."
So when I got around
to where the line was,
she slid her little
black ass around there,
and then some guy, the
guy was gettin' on my case
about takin' cuts, and some other guy
was gettin' on my case about her,
bein' my ass in his face,
and then she came around
the front of me and said,
"Don't trip on what I said,
"I was just playin',"
and I went, I lost it.
I said, "Check this out bitch,"
I said, "your shit's in
my motherfuckin' house.
"my shit isn't at your
motherfuckin' house,
"so how in the fuck you
have an issue with me?
"Because I got issues with you."
That motherfucker took me,
she had a water bottle,
she had a 40 ounce water bottle,
I've never in my life had a woman talk,
that woman cussed me out
and called me every kind of,
motherfucker took that water bottle,
she told me she's bipolar,
I shoulda listened,
she took that fuckin' water bottle
and she hit me up side the head
with that motherfucker.
When she hit me, the water went one way,
and the bottle went the other way,
and my head went this way.
I'm standin' there in
front of the Mission,
and everybody sees this shit.
Now normally, on a normal plane,
I wanted to grab that bitch by her neck
and beat the holy fuckin' shit out of her,
but I knew where I was at.
There was too many LAPD out there,
and for some reason I hadn't had a drink,
I hadn't been drinkin', so thank God,
'cause if I had a drink, I'd have beat
her motherfuckin' ass right there
in the motherfuckin' street,
I woulda dared a motherfucker,
'cause I woulda beat a motherfucker there,
I would've beat that fuckin' bitch's,
I'da beat that fuckin' bitch down.
Fuckin' bitch, how in the fuckin' dare
she fuckin' talk to me like that?
So I told her, I said, "Check this out,
"I'm gonna walk to my house, and your ass
"better walk behind me, 'cause
I'm puttin' out your shit
"all over downtown if you don't get your."
So she's walkin' behind me
and she's cussin' me out,
this what she said, this what gets me,
she's, "Oh, you got up in my face,
"I hit you with the water bottle
"'cause I thought you was gon' hit me."
She said, "You didn't talk
shit to the guys like that,
"you talked shit to me, you a pussy,
"you talk shit to me,
but you didn't talk shit
"to the guys," but the thing was,
I wasn't mad at the motherfuckin' guys,
I was mad at her, because she was the one
that had the shit at my house,
and I was pissed at her all the way.
But because of my self-esteem issues,
she kinda struck a nerve when
the bitch told me that shit,
'cause she got me thinkin',
"Damn, well did I punk out
"with them guys?"
But no, no, I didn't
punk out with them guys,
they didn't make me mad, they put salt
on the shit I was already mad at,
so when she came around with her ugly ass
and said somethin' smart to
me, I just blew up on her.
But she cursed me out
all the way 'til I got
to in front of my place,
and all the people
in front of my house,
they all sittin' outside
and she's cussin' me,
cussin' me, cussin'
me, and let me tell you
how I whoop this bitch ass.
I went upstairs, got all her shit,
now they got my door
where you get in my door
and they got a guard sittin' there,
every now and then there's a guard,
they just pretendin', the
security guard was there,
I was like, "Yes!"
But I didn't know what this lady was gon',
try to fight me, whether
she was gon' try to stab me,
'cause I know she carried a big knife.
But when she was comin' after me dude,
she was threatenin' me
like she wanted to kill me.
I mean, she was a real nigger bitch,
she was a nigger.
So she come from somewhere in Maryland,
Baltimore, Maryland,
anyway, so I came downstairs
with her shit, and the security,
and I put her shit in
front of the security,
I said, bam, came out with the first bag.
Now she downstairs, I
could hear her downstairs
talkin', "I was just playin'
when I said what I said,
"I don't know why he got so mad."
You goddamn motherfucker,
well she was goin' on,
goin' like this.
So the last one, I went
upstairs the second time,
I come down the stairs, I had all her shit
in my motherfuckin' hands,
and I threw it on the ground,
let me, I threw it on the ground and said,
"Bam, that's all of it," and she goes,
"I'm sorry, I apologize."
I didn't say one fuckin'
word, I took my ass upstairs,
went in my room, and I
remember 'cause I'm a Pisces,
when I get that fuckin' mad,
get the fuck out my way.
You don't tell me what I do.
Thank God we was in front of that Mission,
if we wasn't in front of that Mission,
I'd have beat that bitch,
probably try to kill that bitch,
I'd probably beat her to death,
right there in the middle of the street.
I was that fuckin' mad.
So, I'm pacin' the fuckin'
room, pacin' the fuckin' room,
pacin' the fuckin' room,
I'm mad as a motherfucker,
and I got nobody to talk to.
I thought about callin' my
mom, then I couldn't get high,
I had my phone and I said,
"Oh," I'm gon' say this
and then I'm, 'cause I'm talkin' long.
Let me tell you all, give
you some real somethin' I did
that's really, really stupid.
Now I'm talkin' to the crack addicts,
'cause if you did some shit like this,
you ain't the only one.
I got a stimulus check, and I told myself,
"I'm not gon' fuck that
stimulus check off,
"and goddammit, ain't no
crack, ain't no alcohol,
"ain't nothin' in the world gonna make me
"fuck off my stimulus check."
I had $600.
I put half of it on the
rent, I had $200 left.
Now I said, "I'm not
gon', I'm gon' go buy me
"a bass guitar."
I went and bought the most
beautiful fuckin' bass guitar
in the world, and I had that
fuckin' bass for three days.
I couldn't get the damn thing to tune,
'cause you had to fine tune it,
for some reason I couldn't
get that son of a bitch tuned.
I got high and sold it
for a $40 rock of cocaine.
And that bass, when I
got that bass guitar,
that was the furthest thing from my mind,
'cause I'd been wantin' one for so long,
but I've had three of them and gave 'em
to the pawn shop a really long time ago.
And I said, "When I get my bass guitar,
"I'll have somethin' to do, to
keep my mind from bein' idle"
Now every time I sat and I
picked that fuckin' bass up,
and I'm playin' that fuckin' base.
When I took a hit I said,
"I'm gon' take a hit,
"but I'm not gon'," and
the first thing I did
when I took a hit, I ran outta money,
and I sold that goddamn
bass guitar for two $20,
I sold that damn thing for
29, I sold a $200 guitar
for 29 worth of cocaine.
And for about a week I
wouldn't come out my room,
I was so goddamn, I said,
"Damn, I did that shit again."
So if you on cocaine man,
you get hooked on that shit,
if you sell all your, I remember
somebody told me one time,
they said, "Once you get
sober, once you take a hit,
"you might as well sell
all your shit first,
"don't take a hit first,
sell all your shit first.
"Sell your car, sell your bass guitar,
"sell your shoes, sell
your watches, your rings,
"your coats, all your laundry,
coats, sell all your shit,
"and then take a hit,
'cause once you take a hit,"
once I take a motherfuckin' hit,
I don't know, once I exhale, once I,
(Louis inhales and exhales)
all bets are off, I don't know
what the fuck I'm gon' do.
But thank God, this
birthday, I'm not gon' have
no money for that kinda shit,
'cause I gotta pay my rent.
And I'm so glad I could
talk to you guys again.
I hope I helped somebody
with some of my bullshit.
To me it's all bullshit,
but it's all the truth.
And,
I don' feel like makin' up rhymes.
I don't know, I came here today,
I really didn't feel like talkin'.
It took me long enough just to get outta
that goddamn house and start walkin'.
(Louis laughs)
I came down here and saw the car outside,
I said, "This man get mad sometimes,
"even though he wanna cut
somebody's motherfuckin' hide."
So I came down the street,
about halfway down,
he looked out the window,
he looked like a clown.
I said, "Oh shit, I
better keep on walkin',
"he may turn me away."
He said, "No, no man, I
could use you on today."
So I'm glad of that, I appreciate you,
and I'm glad y'all could listen to me
and I'll see you next time.
(Louis laughs)
- [Interviewer] Thank you man.